So it's a new week and we are essentially
at the start of the 2020 election right now.
Now, of course, we've been figuring out who's
going to be the Democratic nominee.
People have been campaigning for a year now.
But what I mean is we are now just weeks,
as I told you last week, from the first votes,
early voting and absentee voting starting
in at least three states in just over five
weeks.
So we need to have a very precise plan for
the next five weeks.
And, of course, for the three months until
the November election.
And the plan as much as being an offensive
plan against Donald Trump in order to remove
Donald Trump, the left needs a defensive plan
as well.
And I mean defense against self-destructive
elements of the left so that we don't self-destruct
and allow Donald Trump to get another four
years in office, which would be I mean, listen,
I don't want to be hyperbolic.
I don't even want to assign language to it
right now because it's not the point of this
story.
But another four years of Trump would be very,
very bad.
Let's put it that way.
And one of the things that we have to be very
careful of right now is for the left to avoid
engaging in fights that right now are irrelevant
and could potentially simply allow Trump to
get another four years.
My advice for the left.
First of all, my advice is for the left and
not for the right, because I'm on the left.
The right is making all sorts of mistakes.
I hope they continue to make mistakes and
we should let them make mistakes.
This is not about giving the right advice.
This is about giving the left advice.
But at the same time, we should understand
how certain fights that are right now irrelevant
don't need to be put aside forever.
We just need to be thinking carefully about
what we're doing.
And that's where I want to go first.
This is not a disclaimer, but it is a clarification.
This is not about compromising progressive
policy or values.
This is just realizing we have three months
left.
We have to come together.
These three months are the last thing we have
to remove Donald Trump.
And we have to put policy differences within
the left that are currently irrelevant aside,
because if Trump wins our chances of getting
anything done or zero.
In other words, the intra left debates, if
Trump wins, will be irrelevant for four more
years, because either way, we're not getting
anything done with Donald Trump in the White
House.
Again, if Joe Biden wins, then we go right
back to these disagreements within the left,
because the point is, what do we want to push
Joe Biden to do?
What can we push Joe Biden to do from the
left?
And if Democrats were able to take the Senate
in November, which is looking more likely
now than it was a month ago, I'll talk about
that later, it becomes an even more important
discussion.
Now, what I'm specifically looking to here
are some of the different wings of the left
where there are disagreements.
And what I want is for everybody to understand
that we don't lose anything by postponing
these disagreements for three months.
And we do ourselves a lot of good without
harming the movement now.
I'll give you some examples to make this really
clear.
I don't want this to just remain some vague
thing, socialism versus social democracy.
OK, this has become a very important, popular,
relevant, heated debate on the left lately.
Right now, that debate does nothing for us.
It actually does nothing for us in two different
ways.
Number one, whether you want socialism or
social democracy, the next step is social
democracy from where we are today.
There's no way the United States is going
to be a socialist country anytime soon.
When Trump warns the Marxists are taking over.
That's not true.
When the right warns the U.S. could become
socialist if Biden wins.
That's not true.
And when the socialist left says we could
have a socialist revolution and be a socialist
country, none of those things are happening
anytime soon.
And so the point is, if you are a socialist,
which I happen not to be, you are going to
have to come through social democracy to get
to socialism.
That's the reality with Biden.
We have the opportunity to get some policy
done that is socially democratic.
If you look at Biden's ideas on health care,
taxation, climate change, clean energy, they're
not exactly what I want.
And I'll address that later.
But they're closer to the direction that both
Social Democrats and Socialists want to go
from where we are today.
So we're not going to finish that fight in
the next three months.
We're just not.
Let's get Trump out and then let's start pushing
Biden in the direction we all agree he needs
to go at some point in the future if we succeed.
Socialism versus social democracy will be
relevant to policy.
It's not the next step.
It's not happening in the next three months.
So why are we going to argue about that right
now when we're trying to remove Donald Trump?
Just some other little example.
Here's one that I thought of just looking
at my Twitter this morning.
There's this journalist, Mehdi Hassan, and
we follow each other on Twitter.
I've read it, retweeted some of his work that
I think is great.
He's retweeted some of our stuff.
We're in agreement about many, many things.
We happen to disagree.
Meti and I about BTX with respect to Israel,
boycott, divestment, sanctions, movement.
I believe that the movement is counterproductive.
I don't think it'll lead to the kind of change
I want to see.
Mehdi Hassan supports Beedi.
Yes.
Great.
It's a disagreement.
It's a completely irrelevant one for the next
three months because we have a president.
I think both Meti and I would agree.
We have a president right now who's in bed
with the worst of the Israeli right and his
support of Benjamin Netanyahu and has the
worst instincts, period, when it comes to
the Israeli-Palestinian conflict.
So we're both against Benjamin Netanyahu.
We're both against Donald Trump.
Trump must be removed.
So why would we argue about.
Yes for the next three months rather than
focusing on removing Donald Trump?
Another example which is maybe more relevant
to you in the immediate single payer health
care.
Trump is not for single payer.
Neither is Joe Biden.
What Joe Biden is proposing is better than
what Donald Trump is proposing.
And most Democrats in the Senate don't even
support single payer health care right now.
So for the next three months, why would we
make the dividing line?
Does Biden support single payer or not?
It makes no sense.
Either Biden or Trump are going to be inaugurated
on January 20th.
Health care will improve if Biden gets his
way.
We can push him to improve it even more, hopefully.
And with Trump, we get nothing.
We get fewer people covered if Trump gets
his way.
So what are we doing now for people who are
going to react very negatively to what I'm
saying?
And they'll write to me and they'll say, David,
you're only saying this because you're not
a socialist and you are a Democratic Party
shill or whatever argument you're going to
make.
You're missing exactly the point that I'm
making, whether or not I'm a Democratic shill.
And by the way, I'm not I'm not even a Democrat
has no bearing whatsoever on the left having
opportunity with Joe Biden and none with Donald
Trump.
That's it.
And it's particularly important right now
not to operate for the next three months in
a way that will serve to divide the left and
give Donald Trump and the right an opportunity
to be elected for another four years, partially
by fomenting this division on the left, which
is exactly what they want to do on January
21st.
If Joe Biden is inaugurated on January 20th,
on January 21st, we have the ball back, as
I like to say, and we immediately go back
to these important discussions.
We immediately go back on January 21st to
seeing the Republicans in the Lincoln Project.
This Republican group trying to remove Trump
as soon as Biden's inaugurated.
They're no longer on our side.
I imagine they immediately go back to advocating
for their so-called small government, conservative
values or whatever.
These are all discussions, you know, about
health care or whatever topic.
We go right back to those discussions.
And in fact, if we do get the ball back, which
I would.
That's how I've been analogizing, removing
Trump and electing Joe Biden once we get the
ball back.
We then have to try to put some points on
the board, and that means arguing about the
right place to call and having these policy
debates.
But at this point, it's July 27.
If we miss the forest for the trees, we're
not just doing the United States a disservice.
We're doing the world a disservice.
Given the level of destruction that Donald
Trump has rained upon this country over the
last three and a half years.
So this is not shut up and get in line with
Democratic Party centrism and cronyism.
That's not what this is about.
This is about we get nothing.
If Donald Trump gets reelected, the world
will hate us even more.
It will ruin our relationships with allies
even more.
It will put us even further behind on climate
change, irreparably so vs..
We get Trump out.
Biden goes in.
Hopefully with a reasonable but reasonable
vice president I.
Which we should know soon.
I want to know who the cabinet will be.
We want to keep looking at the policy and
we have an opportunity.
If Joe Biden gets elected now, there will
be a contingent of my audience that will disagree
on principle with what I'm saying, because
they are in the camp of you've got to burn
it all down to build it back up.
And these are some of the same folks who said
if it's not going to be Bernie in 2016, I
don't care if it's Trump because it will accelerate
the destruction of the country.
Well, we're really no closer to any kind of
socialist revolution as a result of four years
of Trump.
But we are destroying the planet.
We're in the middle of arguably one of the
worst five global responses to this pandemic
corona virus pandemic, which has subsequently
led to an even worse economic disaster than
was NASA.
It.
It's failed that that approach has failed.
And go back and check out my clips where I
point out the progress in the modern political
era has been incremental progress by getting
better people and getting better people on
the Supreme Court and moving things in the
right direction.
So let's come together.
Let's do the right thing.
And I promise you, in three months, we can
get right back to the same divisive debates,
if that's what you want to do, hopefully in
a more productive way with the experience
and hindsight of seeing what we experienced
during the Donald Trump presidency.
If we get another four years of Trump, who
knows what's next, but it's not good.
So let's come together on this issue.
This is not a long time, you know, for people
desperate to talk about a socialist revolution,
to knock out neo liberalism.
And, you know, that wing of of my audience.
Three months is not a long time.
Let's just put that energy to get out the
vote and removing Donald Trump.
It's just three months.
OK.
It's gonna go.
Look, we've been in quarantine for five months.
It's gone by like that because every day looks
very, very similar.
These three months will go by quickly, even
during the transition.
We can get back to these debates, if that's
what that's what you want.
Let's do it.
Let's come together for the next three months.
Let me know where you disagree with me.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
And remember, you can get the daily audio
podcast from the David Pakman show every single
day, right around 3:00 p.m. Eastern, noon
Pacific on any of your favorite or least despised
podcasting apps, whether that's Google Play
podcasts or Spotify, Pandora, I, heart radio,
I tunes, et cetera, et cetera.
Get the daily audio podcast.
Let me know what you think about avoiding
these self-destructive and presently irrelevant
debates on Twitter at David Pakman.
And I will be back with much more just moments
from now.